Tanzania's president has said the
country has been healed of coronavirus
through prayer it is an almighty claim
and difficult challenge because his
government hasn't released any data for
weeks and the doctors who know the truth
are afraid to speak out we have decided
to go this way to depend on God we have
started with thoughts and we shall
finish with him in reality God has
answered our prayers the number of
infected patients is dropping on a list
of countries that the World Health
Organization is most worried about
Tanzania comes top media reporting is
suppressed
journalists are wrigley locked up but
the stories are getting out the
interviewees that we spoke to took risks
to tell us what's happening this doctor
asked us to disguise his identity he's
afraid of losing his job we were
treating people with kovin 19 and those
suspected to have covert 19 when the
pandemic came we were shocked we hadn't
prepared ourselves and we didn't have
any guidelines but we were learning as
we went along there were challenges at
that time the disease was new to us the
doctors were scared there was no
equipment especially PPE we were asking
ourselves how are we going to treat
these patients without PPE vanila
Jacob's father needed emergency dialysis
where the hospitals were too busy
treating coronavirus patients so they
couldn't help him so she shook it we
were told to not come outside a health
officer at the emergency department
asked my father if he had fever and my
father said no a nurse asked if my
father had a sore throat and my father
said no they didn't even want to test
his temperature and they told us it was
not possible to admit us unless we had
tested for coronavirus under rikiya
Jacob died that evening 64 years old
one neighboring country Kenya has closed
its borders with Tanzania and the US
Embassy in the capital dar Salam warned
Americans to stay at home because the
city's hospitals are overwhelmed the
government has allowed markets to stay
open there is no social distancing here
a lockdown would have its own
catastrophic effects people quite simply
would starve and so they have no choice
yeah you made your debut the government
has just provided us with education by
educating us to sanitize and to use
masks but it is not possible to prohibit
gathering at a market like this I need
money I can't chase away consumers there
is no safety here but we only need money
and we have nothing to do we're at risk
we lack customers because they fear
Corona for that we lack capital but we
advise the government as they have
decided that there is no lockdown but we
need the relief fund we can't afford the
health services here during the pandemic
at least if they can provide masks and
sanitizer at a low price it could be
helpful the Tanzanian government
continues to insist there is little to
worry about and coronavirus isn't a
threat to health in the country and
anyone who dares to disagree with that
position is silenced alistair bungle Sky
News